so today now we're going to listen to
Rick ffist who is going to talk us about
balancing the electricity read with
multi-level forecasting models so please
let's give a warm welcome to
[Applause]
Rick thank you welcome everybody thanks
for coming
along today we're going to talk about
the electricity grid
and what we do at s power to keep that
imbalance so first a little bit about
myself I have a background in electrical
engineering then surely slowly shifted
kind of to our signal processing then
did some data science with the energy
disaggregation and sustainability advice
and I'm a machine learning engineer at s
power um so for me it falls really kind
of like full circle of coming from
electrical back ground into data science
but still being somewhere connected to
electricity the agenda for today is
going to be three parts every good
presentation has three parts right first
a little bit of a primer about the
electricity grids and all the things
that you don't think about when you put
your uh plug into the power socket then
something about the different kind of
Time series that we're facing and maybe
how you can reason about what kind of
Time series you're dealing with
and
then forecasting at different levels and
how you can have reconciled or coherent
forecasts across
those so let's start with the primer
you've probably heard this a million
times already there's
a energy transition renewable energies
and uh just a bit of show hands who here
has solar panels on their
roof and who has is driving electric
car and maybe a new category new kid on
the Block who has a heat pump at
home that's great I see a lot of people
are doing a a great Dr job already with
the energy
transition and you're also part of the
problem that we're creating in the
electricity grid so uh no blame that's
all part of uh the problem you need to
solve together so what's the problem
we're having a shift on the production
side
from coal gas oil fired plants to
renewable energies they have more
volatility and they're less
predictable and we have more congestion
because there's also a lot of Lo
localized production right and on the
other side there's the EV there's the
heat pumps there's a lot of electrif
electrification of the demand as
well so how do you keep everything
balanced because if you have an
electricity grid
is different from G gas or water right
or other Commodities you can just put
them in a storage and keep them around
for a while electricity that's really
hard so how do we make sure that the
consumption always equals demand in
electricity G because this is kind of a
hard constraint that we have in
electricity
grid the answer is markets so there's a
lot of different electricity markets um
and there's a difference between trading
markets and balancing markets which
we'll get to a bit so here you see some
of the trading markets right so every
day for the next day or during the day
for the next hour there's a market where
you can say I can supply this much
against this price um and you can say I
want to buy electricity against this
price and this is your classical
economic Supply demand find the
intersection and that's going to be the
price and that's going to be the
volume um also important
when
we so this is how this is the agreement
that you say right I will consume this
much as if consu we as consumers we
don't do that right so big commodity
suppliers do that for us but if you have
a really big Factory and you're using
hundreds of kilowatts or megawatts then
you're also doing this because it
doesn't make sense to always have a
fixed
price now what happens if we have this
increased volatility less predictability
and we're just having a little bit less
sun today than we were expecting
tomorrow and there's an imbalance some
of the supply that we were expecting
suddenly Falls
away and actually the way that we can
measure how much balance there is in the
grid is by the grid frequency so you can
think of it as like a big Spinning Wheel
other producers are kind of like trying
to advance the wheel make it spin faster
and all the demand is taking energy so
at the moment you have a surplus of
Supply then the frequency goes up and if
you have too much demand it goes
down so to do this kind of like response
to disturbances there's the balancing
surfaces so again the solution is we'll
just make a new market for the balancing
service there's a lot of different
markets out there you can see them on
the slide I don't expect you uh at the
end of the talk to know all the all the
services but basically whenever there's
a deviation in the frequency which you
can see up top somebody needs to respond
right because other if we don't respond
to frequency deviations in the grid
we're going to end up with the grid
collapse because a lot of things depend
on this 50 HZ on the grid so there's
some for slow response middle response
longer response different response times
different uh
intensity but
basically balancing responsible parties
can bid and say okay I have 10 megawatt
or 100 megawatt that I can turn off or
on whenever there's a deviation and this
is what we trade in in the balancing
Market you don't trade in the energy but
you trade in being available or being
standby to respond Whenever there is a
deviation so if you want to make a bid
you have to say how many megawatts do I
have available and what price do I want
to be uh stand
by so this is also again getting back to
the whole energy
transition this balancing responsible
party traditionally it's a lot of The
Producers right so you have a coal or
again a gas bar uh bar
flant
and traditionally you'd have a lot of
load following so whenever demand goes
up or down you just scale up your load
up and down and that way you can respond
to frequency
deviations
now what we're trying to do with Z power
and what you see more and more is to
also have demand side flexibility so
instead of only the producer going up
and down and trying to match whatever
the demand is you can also say
hey if we have too much solar energy all
of a sudden maybe we can turn something
on that's consuming that energy or other
way around if there's a sudden high
demand maybe some of the big producers
can also shut down
so
um this is what we're trying to do
finding big customers that have a really
high electricity
consumption and that could benefit by
being in this balancing market so
imagine you're um a big resource like a
greenhouse you have the lights on for
most of the day um and maybe every once
in in a two weeks you get all of a
sudden you get an alert saying okay the
frequency is out of balance now you need
to turn off the light for 10
minutes and the plants okay the plants
they don't they won't suffer that much
if you put the lights offer 10 minutes
over two week period
right so this is the business that s
power is in
finding industries that have some
potential for the Manti flexibility
installing some hardware and then every
now and then there will be a signal
signal everything needs to shut down now
for 10 minutes or it needs to ramp up
for 10 minutes and then bringing that
together as a big pool into the
balancing
market so um you came here also for data
and forecasting and time series
forecasting so how does this whole
energy transition story relate to
forecasting well we as a aggregator need
to make a bid saying we're going to have
X megawatts available tomorrow on
standby to now how much we have
available we need to know what
electricity consumption there is so say
if you have a greenhouse which is
operating at 500 kilowatt but they have
some additional lamps that they can turn
on they can scale up to a megawatt or
they can scale down to zero Watts so
they have like 500 kilowatt of
flexibility in every
direction
if we want to forecast that that means
we need to forecast the power
consumption of those industrial
appliances so that we know what
flexibility we can also offer um to the
grid operator which is the one that's
managing the the balancing markets so
this is how the whole pooling of demand
side flexibility relates to um time
series
forecasting we made it through the first
part second second part is going to be
what kind of Time series are we dealing
with and how can we reason about them
and then in the third part we will get
to the multiple aggregation levels in
forecasting so this is some very raw
data um relatively high resolution the
bids only need to be made in like an
hourly basis but you see three big
industrial resources here you see
electric boiler a heat pump and an oven
or a
furnace and you see each of them has
their own characteristics of course it's
the electricity signal so typically it
doesn't go below zero and also what you
see is a lot of the resources they have
kind of like a Max rated capacity right
for example this electricity boiler you
can see it has some heating element in
there probably and if it's running at
six megawatts it's never going
higher and you see some kind of like
production Cycles so if you look at the
below sample of the Furnace
you can really clearly see
there's some material like maybe metal
is loaded into the furnace then it needs
to heat up really hard it's using a lot
of power and once the metals start to
come to temperature the power
consumption kind of trails off um and
then whatever next operation I know it's
cast or maybe it's sheet formed until
the next comes in so this is what you
see in the blow graph you see this clear
patterns in the electricity
consumption
so this got us thinking me and I have to
say the other machine learning engineer
that's working a lot on this uh
oi how can we reason about those kinds
of Time series models um there's this
book called intermittent demand
forecasting and by the way whenever you
see a number in the square brackets it's
a reference so if you think this is
interesting write down the number at the
end I will show the references and then
you can access the material
so here you see a number of categories
of Time series so the the top left one
is called ertic because it's mostly on
but when it's on it has a relatively
High
variant then the top right one is
sometimes on sometimes off and when it's
on it's also fluctuating a lot so high
variant or high variability there's a
smooth one which is almost always on um
and also low variant and then the bottom
one it's a bit hard to see because it's
only on for short periods of time but
this is a greenhouse and typically the
greenhouses when they're on they are
really steady so low variance um but
they're not always on because if the
stands out you're not going to also put
on the
lights so we put it in this little
diagram and is not a diagram that we
made it from the the book that you can
see here there's basically two axes one
of them is demand intervall or
intermittence and the other one is the
variance of the non-zero values or ertic
you could also call it and in this way
you can
classify erratic lumpy intermitted and
smooth uh smooth as four different
series The thing is we have a lot of
groups of similar resources in our pool
and you can imagine that this erratic
and
intermittent is really quite difficult
to forecast we have a lot of zeros and
you might not know exactly when it's
zero and non zero but when you group
together
resources typically it will make them
more smooth so you can see example the
greenhouses so if you look at this
period May
17th on the left you see three
individual green houses on the right you
see a pool of about a 100 green houses
some together and you see for the
individual ones there's kind of like a
chance they might have the lights on on
that day or they might turn the lights
off on that
day so you can imagine and this is going
to be a bit handwavy statistics but if
they have a somewhat similar probability
of the decisions they make of when to
put the lights on or when to put them
off
that distribution that's behind it kind
of seeps through if you see the
aggregated signal right so in the
individual ones it's really hard binary
zero or one it's on or off but if you
look at the aggregation you see a more
smooth curve of the the patterns that
the Green Houses make so
this want to give one more example of
this also the furnaces individually you
see they are really hard to time because
they may some of the a lot of the
Furnace have the similar pattern of this
heating cycle that I just
showed um but they might have different
length and they might also have
different timings and also the timing
intervals are not consistent but if you
pull them together you see that a lot of
this for example the intermittent so the
zeros they kind of go away and also the
relative variant also get
lower so this is my kind of like uh
proposition aggregation promotes smooth
smoothness so if you have ertic lumpy or
intermittent time series if you do some
aggregation over different levels or
over time then you get a more smooth
signal and typically smooth signals are
easier to forecast than nons smooth
signals there's ways also for doing
forecasting on intermittent time series
um but usually it requires some special
techniques the issue is
so for our bid bidding process usually
it's fine if we can just have one bid
with regard to the TSO but if you are
operations analyst maybe you want to say
okay what happens if I take out this
research right so business requires a
low level of detail um and if you think
of a different example maybe a
store um okay it's nice to know what all
the things combined are consuming but
you also want to have some lower level
Insight of like an individual store so
we have this kind of of trade-off
between high level of
detail on one side and something that's
better to forecast on the other side so
the question is how can can we do both
at the same time What strategies are
there for
getting forecast on the aggregate level
but also getting the individual
forecasts and I want to discuss four
different
strategies the first of first of them is
called bottom up forecasting
um there's a lot of things you see on
the slid but it's relatively simple so
if the t's are the individual time
series then you train a model on each of
the time series they get a forecast for
each of the time series so here there's
three time series three models three
forecast you forecast the lowest level
first that's why it's called bottom up
and then you do an aggregation and then
you have a aggregation aggregated
forecast but it does mean you have to
deal with intermittent tic is all the
the hard stuff
basically the other way you could do
this is top down forecasting so instead
of forecasting the individual time
series you first sum all the time series
together and again I'm taking an example
of different groups of Time series but
this can also mean over time right over
a week or over month you could also
Aggregate and then you somehow have to
distribute down
this grouped forecast into the
individuals and the simplest thing you
could say is just spread it uniformly or
you could take historical proportions of
sites or there's also some methods where
you um Can forecast the proportions if
they are changing over time of course
it's going to not going to give you as
much detail but maybe if you're
forecasting for stores and they are all
quite similar this could be a good
approach as
well third approach if we have bottom up
and top down why not do both at the same
time and this this field is called
forecast reconciliation so do both you
have the bottom up forecast or like the
lowest level forecast and you forecast
the highest
level but to make sense towards your
Stak holders you need to find some way
to make them match right
so one uh example of how you could do
this is called minimal Trace
reconciliation where you basically
Define a matrix that says how the lws
level sum up to the higher hierarchical
levels in your time series and then you
do some
optimization on that Matrix to make sure
that you get a consistent output so your
output of this is having the lowest
level and the highest level um forecast
and actually there's a python package
which implement this uh method and uh
other one so if you're interested in
that I would check that
out the final method I want to talk
about is called Global
forecasting um and this is an approach
where essentially this is a form of
bottom up but instead of training
individual models for each of your time
series you just basically concat
concatenate all your time series put
them in a single
model and then also get outputs of uh
the IND indidual forecast and maybe you
want to include like an identifier or
something
um as a feature also in this model for
example the category of the resource you
could
include
and there's a really interesting paper I
which I recommend which is called prin
principles and algorithms for
forecasting groups of Time series
locality and
globality
um I found this a really interesting
read because what they are claiming in
this paper
you think okay if I have just one model
to train on lots of different time
series then it's going to be more
restrictive
right what they claim in this paper is
that it's not necessarily more
restrictive and to give you kind of like
a Layman summary of what they're
claiming in the in the in the paper is
that the local model naturally has a
more of a tendency to overfit because it
has a shorter history or less samples to
train on um and relatively more model
parameters to kind of learn the training
data and thus overfit on the test
data of course a global model will need
more parameters to kind of like achieve
the same performance as the local ones
um but if you compare
overall then the global model maybe it
needs 10 times or 20 times as much
parameters as each of the individual
local models but if you have 100
different time series
that's
still less kind of like parameters to
overfit on your data that's one and each
of the if you're having some lag based
model so Auto regressive model then for
each of it in the individual time series
that you forecast you can get away with
having more lags so you can include more
history into your forecast and this is
basically the premise in this paper they
play try to explain why is the global
forecasting model doing so good because
they found in a lot of competitions was
doing quite well um so I recommend it
then there's also a book which also
discusses this uh quite
well so on our some of our
results um you see that the performance
that we got with the aggregate model
actually was quite close to the
performance that we got with the global
model even though the aggregate model
was doing like a nice this is compared
uh on the aggregate level so I'm
comparing the forecasting on error on
the aggregate level and the nice smooth
forecast on the aggregate level got
similar performance as kind of like the
bottom up Global forecasting
method the normal bottom up here I have
to put it bit of a disclaimer not fully
representative because the model that
we're comparing there we also made some
other tweaks to it the point I wanted
trying to make is in our
experience the global method could do as
well as forecasting on the can of like
the nice smooth aggregate
level
so that was the three
parts we talked a little bit about
energy and balancing markets and how
they play an important real role in
keeping our grid stable all the things
that we have to think about together if
we want to move away from fossil
fuels we learned that intermittent d
time series uh this applies to kind of
like power series but it might also be I
think most time series if you go to
really low level if you think of the the
sales at a store if you go down to the
minute level it's also going to be
intermittent right because a small store
is not going to sell something in
everything um so they require different
approaches from smooth ones but maybe
you can get around it if you do some
different level of
aggregation and we learned about what
different Tech techniques that exist to
make reconciled forecast of the
individual and any aggregation of the
forecast that you might
have here's the references
slide um take a picture all the things
with the hyperlinks that you can see are
openly accessible some of the other ones
are
books um so you'd have to get
those and um that was my
talk thank you so much
[Music]
[Applause]